so I have done a video talking about
Stargate going International
and it's confused a lot of people so let
me just add this little bit of addendum
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
right so I talked in my last video about
this business model idea sort of copying
what Amazon have done with a citadel
where they have created The Citadel show
the main show set in the west west
actors blah blah English actors American
actors but and then they are planning to
do
um a bunch of series that are more for
international markets so India like its
own Citadel show based in India
um Australia might blah blah blah
and I suggested that that might be a
brilliant idea for Stargate that you
could create International TV shows
produced internationally so for example
say India 1.4 billion potential Gators
you could create a TV show produced by
an Indian production company obviously
paid for by Amazon Prime
um that actually has Indian actors that
they um at least in part speak
um their native languages and but I also
think also at least partly in English
because actually they do speak English a
lot in India
um but then that it would be primarily
for the market of India
but if it's done well a high enough
standard and there is enough English
involved Etc it could be a TV show that
we would then watch here as well that it
would be within Universe within Canon it
would be at least in some ways related
to the what I would call the main TV
show that would be produced um in
probably in the United States
that there is only one Stargate at the
end of the day so there is one main show
where the actual Stargate is
and that then what we could end up
getting is say four or five TV series
running every year you could have
Stargate the main show Stargate Alpha
site Stargate Australia Stargate Indian
sg9 or something
um maybe a Chinese show based aboard a
BC 306 that would be again a Chinese
group Taps maybe they speak Chinese
occasionally maybe they speak English a
fair bit as well it is a show that could
really have one foot in both continents
now a lot of people have said look I
don't want this because I want it to be
in English I don't want a show that goes
out of Canon
say an Indian production company wants
to go a different way
and I understand that but what we really
do need to remember is sometimes maybe
didn't explain in the original video
very well is this would be a way
to get TV shows that otherwise wouldn't
get made
wouldn't get funded
so you produce a TV show specifically
for the Indian audience the Indian
market
you can get that funded reasonably
locally
that is a TV show that otherwise
wouldn't be made
so it would add to Canon
I would love the idea of like the movies
pulling in bits and threads from all the
different series
but at the same time they they could be
series that you might not watch
in the same way that we get a lot of
Spanish TV and things like that on
Netflix and whatever else I don't
necessarily watch it
I also think though that this is not
only a good business model it's good
Financial sense
for Amazon
it's also very good at spreading the
Stargate word
so we get more Gators more popularity
equals more TV more movies more
everything
but also it is probably the future
and I think because of streaming we
became becoming more used to seeing
these sort of TV shows she likes TV
shows from North Korea and South Korea
North Korea television would be very
different South Korea
a lot of TV shows are being made in sort
of North Africa in Nigeria and places
like this and we will watch it here now
I'm not a massive fan of reading my
television but
they could mix languages up they could
use a bit of native language so that it
is still interesting but also actually
have a bit of English because it is
probably the most spoken language on the
planet
so I actually think this is a really
interesting possibility from a business
point of view
from an entertainment point of view and
it wouldn't take away from anything that
we would have got anyway and that's
really the important point that I think
a lot of people are maybe stressing out
about
it's a thing a thinking I don't want my
Stargate show to have a bunch of Chinese
in it because I'm not going to
understand it
the Chinese Stargate show made
specifically for that market might have
some Chinese in but it doesn't
necessarily mean our star game would
it's an addition
I'm hoping that's a little bit clearer
also I don't say that this is an idea
that was put forward by Jenny Steven I
think it was a brilliant idea
it is not something that we've heard
from our sources at Amazon necessarily
but it is something that Amazon are
doing with other television shows so we
wanted to discuss the possibility
get into the comments go tell me what
you think
and I'd love to know if you think this
is just a bad idea for other reasons
other than you know the language barrier
are there actual practical reasons that
we're not thinking about of why this
maybe wouldn't work I'd love to know get
in the comments as always please like
subscribe hit the Bell notification
don't forget to go to patreon.com
Sidetrack where you get to see most of
my videos first and you know generally
be happy and I'll speak to you soon
oh
[Music]